we're gonna kick the show off with a
white british man doing a freestyle rap
so everyone here think of a word or a
topic or a phrase you'd like to hear a
rap about there are some rules don't
suggest food or animals it's too boring
don't stress anything too obvious don't
say anything that i've mentioned don't
be like oh the queen and uh be creative
be imaginative try and challenge me what
would you like a rap about jaden smith
jaden smith cool do you know him
yeah no i don't know why did you lie
that wasn't that's cool
cool it's weird because you looked i
think maybe i'm trying to think how you
made that connection you probably looked
at me you were like he's a white rapper
will smith essentially a white rapper
and he's a bit corny um okay jaden smith
jaden smith if you don't know is the son
of will and jada pickett smith and uh
and he's uh you know he's he's in the
asap rocky potato salad video in the
background he's a handsome guy he took a
he took um a picture of himself as his
date to like the met gala a few years
ago that's fun um cool
uh tampa what would you like a rap about
the education system in florida isn't
very good they're not
not quick off the mark
yeah but no no you can you can give me
your favorite fruit we'll rap about your
favorite fruit that's fine
peaches i don't know no that's cool it
does florida florida's oranges george's
peaches isn't it you're not like state
represent like i only eat oranges down
no peaches okay so peaches jaden smith
let's come to my my welsh man by way of
nothing here what would you like a rap
about let's go flux capacitor flux
capacitor he has a lovely accident i
can't do a welsh ax and when i do a
welsh accent it kind of strays into
indium
great so flux capacitor which if you
don't know tamper that's from the movie
back to the future
um front row hey what would you like a
rapper oh you're pointing you're like
the boss here everyone's just pointing
at you just like he knows
healthcare socialized healthcare cool
are you involved in that is that part of
like your job
you're uninsured so you're like please
demand it okay that's cool socialize
healthcare it's bro uninsured it's good
that you're wearing such short shorts to
get all that vitamin d you know that's
what you want just every little square
inch of skin so socialized healthcare
flux capacitor peaches and um the jaden
smith uh
two single ladies who were sat together
what would you like a wrap
pocket [ __ ] okay
yeah is that that's the that look in the
uk they're called fleshlights right
that's i'm thinking it's like put your
dick in it yeah
yeah in the uk
i
okay i was going to come to you guys but
i think pocket [ __ ] has topped us out
as a great suggestion so pocket [ __ ]
socialized healthcare flux capacitor
jaden smith and peaches this is going to
be a freestyle that's a wrap made up on
the spot base and telling their
suggestions and do not worry it's not
anywhere near as atrociously
embarrassingly tough only bad as you're
expecting it to be let's drop that beat
let's have a little chuckle have a
little bit of fun um and you can turn up
a little bit as well with you that's uh
that's nice yeah that feels good it
drops in with the base it's gonna be
it's quite chill i chose a nice chill
one
yeah we got suggestions you're giving me
the answer the nice fruit understand
their man from tampa within reach go
down georgia for the beach got the nice
supple orange like the sand on a beach i
can see that oh i tell you the truth let
me get my own blade and i'm licking up
the juice it's amazing the little
sucrose
when you're working on the [ __ ] you can
go up and down that don't drop it i'm
talking about the [ __ ] that i store in
my pocket
right in the front that's the [ __ ] that i
move maybe get
[ __ ] i'm like have you got the sizes
he's like i've got the large medium and
small and i'm like do you have the extra
small cause i like the [ __ ] time he
says
he's [ __ ] underage i'm like [ __ ] i
shouldn't mention the [ __ ] on stage the
pocket [ __ ] you know we like moving
over here yeah shape of
not the letter from the alphabet but the
theme that gets you back in time seeing
doc brown and martin are flying their
damn minds they were so crazy getting
the delorean if you've never seen the
movie this [ __ ] will be boring but it's
fine made by the gmc the general motors
corporation you can even see did one two
three the thirds in the wild west need
to get the flux capacitor better than
the rest i think they dealt with the
libyans nuclear power and let me talk
about jaden smith for two hours well i
know very little facts other than uh his
parents are black and he's looking
pretty flat and he's coming
i wanna try and do a fly rapper
did it take off now nobody's aware they
don't know what he does got the
healthcare he doesn't pay for it he's
probably got it on his parents cause
they're rich but you're like nah they
should share it they should pay their
fair share of tax and then you'd be
insured and you could just relax but
sadly now you're like oh [ __ ] i really
gotta miss my nips doctor's appointment
the dermatologist can't look at any
moles or any skin tags we need to put
republicans in some bin bags that's a
trash bag but the whole phrase round
bernie sanders stands up for you this
time he was like yeah we want the health
care don't alarm you it won't harm you
the healthcare from obama but still you
only get it if you've got a little bit
of money if you're earning too much
they're looking at you funny still
healthcare is good don't push me and
just be careful don't get you [ __ ] stuck
in the [ __ ]